يتصدران مشهد الحرب البارده بين مرشحي
الحزب الجمهوري او مرشحي لحزب الجمهوري في
السباق الى البيت الابيض المعركه
الانتخابيه بين الرجلين بدات بعد ما قرر
ديسنتس اعلان ترشحها رسميا عبر تويتر ولكن
من هو المرشح المفضل للجمهوريين لنيل لقب
سيد البيت الابيض بعدما اكدت المشاهدين
استطلاعات الراي بان ديسانس الاوفر حظا
للفوز بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري والمرشحون
الجمهوريون المعلنون الاخرون وابرزهم طبعا
نكهه التي لا يتجاوزون الخمسه بالمئه فقط
من الاصوات طريقه ديسنتوس الى البيت
الابيض لن تكون سهله لكنه عمل منذ انتخابه
حاكما لولايه فلوريد عام 2018 بعدما تلقى
الدعم اي دعم ترامب الذي كان رئيسا يومها
على نقيه بنفسه ورفع من شعبيته من خلال
مواقفه المحافظه جدا على صعيد التربيه او
الهجره الحزب الجمهوري بشكل عام طبعا
سيدعم ترامب لان دي سانتوس لم يكن سوى
استمرار لسياسه ونهج ترامب في الحكم وحتى
شخصيه ترامب لكنه ليس ترامب يقول هنا
الخبراء الذين اوضحوا بان ديسانتس يراهن
على فوزه من خلال فرضيه عدم خوض ترامب
للانتخابات سواء بسبب اوضاع قانونيه او
اوضاع صحيه ليبقى ترامب الاكثر تفضيلا لدى
الجمهوريين لسبب قاعدته الشعبيه الكبيره
والاحصاءات التي تشير الى انه يتمتع بدعم
حوالي اربعين بالمئه من الاصوات بين 34
الى 40% من الاصوات الانتخابيه للجمهوريين
في معسكره الذين سيصوتون له في الانتخابات
التمهيديه تحت اي ظرف وهنا مشاهدينا لابد
من الاشاره الى انه في الانتخابات
التمهيديه لا يحتاج المرشحون الى اغلبيه
بل يحتاجون فقط الى الفوز بفارق صوت واحد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات